why do we cry
our tears a window into some depths that
we ourselves don't know
i almost want to make fun of myself with
that question but you do talk seriously
about crying in the book in fact the
whole first chapter really really
tussles with crying as a as why do we do
it what does it mean why is it
involuntary it seems like a weakness
right it's because it's so involuntary
and it's reflecting something true and
inside
at the level of the individual that
seems like a problem right wouldn't it
be better if we could control it if if
we could
not show that emotion
when it's not useful show it when it's
useful but it's not it's it's largely
involuntary
and so
there's a value to it i think as a as an
honest reporter of a need of of hope
and frailty at the same time i i'm a
human being
there's a frail
a frailty to myself or my situation
where i need social help i need help
from my community
i have hope that that is possible
but
i'm not enough for myself i need the
community that that i think is what the
the social signal of crying is now
people have studied crying
uh it's an extreme you can you can
quantify
the extent to which the presence of
tears on a face
triggers
reactions in onlookers and
and you can show the same face in the
presence or absence of tears and show
that to to people under quantifiable and
rigorous uh you know
psychological conditions
and
tears are much more powerful at stirring
the desire to help
in
viewers than any other
facial
feature
which is pretty interesting that it's
the it's the honest one that's also the
most powerful right it kind of indicates
there's a certain logic to our design
at as social beings that we have an
honest
report
that's hard to uh hard to control and
but is it is it well understood
what how that connects to
the internal state
of emotion
yeah
there are
long projections that come so where
where's crying generate this is the
confusing thing about it so that we have
a little tear duct the lacrimal gland
that leads to the release of fluid it
ejects fluid and it comes out and those
of course
that whole system was designed to keep
the eye clean to wash out particulate
irritants so it's it's a long standing
as long as we've had eyes and have been
out of the water
uh in our evolution we've needed this
sort of thing so long-standing
biological structure recently co-opted
it seems by our evolution as social
primates
now how could that happen well the
lacrimal gland is controlled by
structures in the pons which is a
structure deep in our
just above our neck between our neck and
our head
and reflecting its ancient origin right
as you go farther down toward the spinal
cord these are the more basic early
evolved structures and and in the ponds
that's where breathing is controlled
tear
duct
uh contraction
and
what we found and with optogenetics we
helped uh sort this out there are long
range projections from fear and anxiety
regions in the forebrain
that project all the way to the ponds
in and around those areas the reason
those are there
we think is to regulate
the respiratory rate changes the
breathing changes of fear and anxiety so
we know when we're in a state of fear
and anxiety we need
we cope better if we have elevated heart
rate elevated respiratory rate more
blood pumping around more oxygenated
blood we're ready to meet the threat if
it happens
all those cells are down there in the
ponds too right next to
the lacrimal glock duct the tear gland
neurons and so almost certainly
this
fear anxiety-induced
crying arose from a very slightly
misdirected long-range projection that
was there
to regulate
breathing and a little twist just a
little misdirection a little missing
of one sign post to stop here going on a
little farther
getting to the lacrimal gland neurons
gave us crying
and that's and we just have it that that
peculiar sort of structure neuronal
structure that resulted in that that's
that's that's what we're stuck with and
then and ends up being in terms of
social interaction one of the more
important
uh authentic
involuntary displays of interstate
that's right and social communication
oh
yeah is there other stuff like that i
mean do you
yeah i mean the human face is
fascinating as a display of emotion as a
display of
truth and lying and all those kinds of
things i personally
i mean we're all i suppose
have different
uh sensors that are sensitive to certain
aspects of the human face but to me it
seems like uh the eyes are really
important communication or something
you know i've talked to a few sort of
girls about like botox and stuff like
that it always bothers me when i guess
guys could do this too but like
when women
uh speak negatively of i guess you can
call them wrinkles at the uh at the tips
of of an eye but like to me when you
smile
when you
wait not wink but like
narrow the eyes to communi something is
communicating and those that stuff is
really useful the human face and when
it's gone that something is missing and
a lot of little stuff it feels like
really it's almost involuntary i guess
but it's harder to describe as the
presence or absence of tears it's like
something about this person you can tell
they're not bullshitting you yeah yeah
and so that was that was what made
presumably that that
tier recruitment so powerful is it just
landed in this very
high value real estate for social
communication if it had gone to you know
there's a lot of
neurons in the in the ponds that control
you know movement of
large you know muscles uh you know
elsewhere that would have been much less
effective as a social signal than
something around the eye so it was
however that that little misdirection
happened it landed in a great area for
social communication
and because it was coming from the fear
and anxiety
circuits that regulate that necessary
involuntary change in
heart rate and respiratory rate
it also was involuntary and that became
valuable as a as a truth signal as as
social beings
so
very interesting when you think about
the origins of the human family the
origins of social
structures and our ability and need to
call for help when there's hope
but but need at the same time
you